Ngày mùa tháng 2 thứ trường của Ngài Giang Ngà Hoa Seph Gề Ria Côp,
cho biết Mác Sức Và đã sẵn sẵn đường mắt với một tự tế mời khi hiệp ước hạt nhân NewsDART
thuả thuận kệm xót của khí hạt nhân quay cùng, giữa Ngà và Mỹ sẽ hết hưởng lực của Ngà 1 năm.
Pháp biểu trong chuyện thả bắc kênh, O Ria Côp cho biết, lếu không đàn được thuả thuận mời và phút chót,
Ngà và Mỹ là đầu tiên sau hơn nữa thế ki, sẽ không còn chưa bất ký dời hàn và giảm buộc nào lối với bu khí hạt nhân trên lược tầm xà.
NewsDART vẫn lực tý năm tháng in hủ trăm mời quy định mức trận một tý năm trong năm mới đầu đả hạt nhân mỗi lược được trên khai.
Theo ông Ria Côp, Mác Sức Và đã để sốt kết tục tân thu, các dưới hàn của thếp ước thêm một năm để tạo không ra, cho các cuộc thật tất cả theo,
sau phía Mỹ chưa được ra phản hội chính thức, ông Nhật Biod Washington không trả lời của phản ánh lập trường của họ.
Dù vậy, Ngà khẳng Đi, sẽ không bị hiểu khếp để la vào một cuộc trạng vô cùng trăm mời.
Đi của chính là trò biết của chính khi đã hóa mụ vá hàn nhân, gồm được lượng trên bộ trên không và trên biển bùng á đàn phát triển và lời.
Chúc đó, kêu thống thống Mỹ và Rect của Bà Mà người trực tiếp kiên newsdark cùng kêu thống thống á,
này là phó chủ tịch hội đồng án định đi mình truyền mất để đẹp cạnh báo.
Vì ở khiệp lất hay đều lực có thể làm soại mọi lòng tin và làm gia tâm,
vui cơ trạng của phụ trạng tọn câu.
Con ông Mát để đẹp thì cho rằng đây là mối lo trong cuộc cà thế giới, nhéu không có cơ trở thay thế.